let's talk movies now nope
yup
nope
you were at their big hollywood premiere
last night i was and i mean there's
something about the stars loving to be
scared out of their minds unlike you i
mean everybody showed up for jordan
peel's new horror flick and oh my god
kiki palmer she showed up and showed out
no she did
is that all you've eaten it's a pickle
is that it
when this outfit was set up he's exactly
right all i had was a pickle
kiki skipped dinner and got glam along
with steph and aisha curry as well as
michael b jordan and lupita nyong'o who
walked the carpet in support of their
black panther co-star daniel kaluya who
won't be returning to wakanda for the
sequel doing this so it's
um it's a shame but it's um
i'm so happy they're doing this we'll
see mike just now see tisha's here you
know it was family he took a picture
with your mom at your billboard how cool
was that
i'm so happy for you
thank you mom this is awesome my mom
she's always been my acting coach and
partner so for us to get to this moment
together it's us summer blockbuster is a
first for me even after 20 years yeah
nah nah nah one
nope hits theaters friday and while the
plot has been kept under wraps the
sci-fi thriller does reunite daniel with
his get out director jordan peel for the
third time daniel and i you know that's
like my my dream collaborator as a
director so yeah that's my brother right
there explain what this movie is about
in one sentence if you could it's about
spectacle
and r
that's a comma
and our
decision
and our obsession with attention well
guest kelly rowland was a spectacle in
this sheer cut out mugler gown but was
tight-lipped about beyonce's renaissance
i know you've heard beyonce's album how
is it
hi i don't know what you're talking
about how's that out
come on now
[Music]